Android 2.0 provides new API s and
technologies for developers this
platform release includes new
capabilities in accounts management
contacts and sync there is now an
account manager API that enables a
developer to store centrally account
credential info on the device the
contacts application supports syncing
and aggregating contacts data from
multiple accounts and the sync adapters
API provides full two-way contact sync
to any back-end quick contact provides
users a fast easy way to communicate
with others selecting the picture frame
shows all communication methods
available and selecting an icon here
Gmail lets users start communicating
right away but this features available
and not just contacts note how it's here
in the messaging application the quick
contacts API lets developers build this
feature into any app Android 2.0
includes the Bluetooth API that lets
apps turn on a devices Bluetooth
discover and connect to nearby devices
and send and receive data here is a demo
game that takes advantage of the api's
capabilities the Bluetooth API now
enables apps to integrate easily
features such as peer-to-peer
communication and proximity based social
interactions the platform began
supporting devices with different screen
sizes starting with Android 1.6 in this
example the places directory app renders
correctly on three different screens
with a single version of the application
using the Android UI toolkit developers
can easily build a single binary to
support devices with various screen
sizes and resolutions to learn more
about the Android 2.0 release visit
developer.android.com